we get it it is national thank a mail
carrier day
exactly in honor of their service here
are a few fun facts
the first organized mail service here in
the u.s was established in 1775
founding father benjamin franklin the
first postmaster general stamps were
invented in 1847
zip codes have been around since 1963.
now
it is possible to thank your mail
carrier with a letter itself and
actually mail it to the letter or you
can do it in person either
way is fine either way is fine what a
thought
sean i wonder what they break down the
third wall they didn't have zip codes
before
63. you know it was a strange it was a
wild time back then in the early 60s
leading up to that we really didn't
really buckle down until 1962 that's
when real modern america started okay
all right just kidding well okay we have
a lot more news weather and traffic
coming up this morning we also have
a live a live report this morning with
our kevin martin she'll be back in tampa
this morning that's coming up at six
so don't go anywhere we got a lot more
coming up on